everyone's trying to get an edge I mean
everyone's trying to get whatever Edge
they can
um you could have someone's whole game
plan they can mail it to you you still
got to stop it you still got to stop it
so in football is is not as pronounced
As baseball if I know a curveball is
coming I'm I'm I got you you
know with with football I don't give it
D if you know a sweep is
coming you still got to stop it
physically you it's a physical game you
got to stop it so that that's a little
tough I don't buy into a lot of that
stuff that someone stealing this
stealing that I don't I don't buy into a
lot of that stuff you still got to play
the game back in our Glory Days with San
Francisco as well as the Cowboys you
know during well em Smith is getting the
ball you know D well Mike Irving is
running the comeback you know ding well
Jay no is going to do what he's going to
do and you couldn't stop it